before moving on I want to address
problem 180 again because we got it
right in the last video but then as soon
as I finish the video I realize it was a
much much simpler way of doing that they
said in a nationwide poll and people
were interviewed one-fourth of them
answered yes one-fourth answered yes to
question one and of those one-third
answered yes to question two so then you
have another one-third so how many
people what fraction of the entire
population said yes to both what would
be one-fourth of one-third or one-third
of one-fourth which is equal to
one-third of one-fourth which is equal
to 1/12 1/12 of the population said yes
to both or you could say 1/12 of n said
yes to both and they just and they asked
us which of the following expressions
represents the number of people
interviewed who did not answer yes to
both so is everybody else this these are
the people who said yes to both so we
essentially just subtract that from 1 so
1 minus 1 12 is equal to 12 12 minus 1
12 which is equal to 11 12 some of the
population did not say yes to both and
so 11 12 and then the population is n so
it's 11 n over 12 and that's that's how
we got choice e problem 181 the ratio of
two quantities is 3 to 4 so let's say
quantity 1 is X 1 is y and it equals 3
to 4 if each of the quantities is
increased by 5 what is the ratio of
these new quantities x + 5 x + 5 - y + 5
well it it really depends on what
multiple these are of 3 & 4 I mean I
could and write and write well I already
have a sense that it's choice e it
cannot be determined from the
information given and let's let's prove
it let's I'm going to show you two
different X's and Y's and when you add 5
to both you're gonna get a completely
different answer so you cannot determine
it from the from the information so they
they snuck in a data sufficiency
question into the problem solving so one
you know X could be 3 if X is equal to 3
and Y is equal to 4 that definitely
satisfies this condition or we could
have X is equal to 6 and Y is equal to 8
right that also satisfies a 3 to 4
what happens when we add five to both of
these X plus 5 X plus 5 would be equal
to 8 and y plus 5 would be equal to 9 so
the new ratio becomes 8 to 9 but what in
this what about this case you would have
X plus 5 is equal to 6 plus 5 which is
11 and then y plus 5 is equal to 8 plus
5 which is 13 and 8 9 is a very
different fraction than 11 13 so it's
not like you can reduce one into the
other so I can find an x and y that
satisfy this but when I add 5 to the top
and bottom I get two different answers
so you cannot determine this with the
information given so the choice is a
sneaky data sufficiency problem 182 182
if the average arithmetic mean of x and
y is 60 and the average so essentially
you're saying X plus y over 2 is equal
to 60 that's the average of them is 60
and the average of y&z is 80 so y plus Z
over 2 is equal to 80 what is the value
of Z minus X so let's see if we can do
that so let's let's rewrite this let's
solve for a solve for X in terms of Y so
we get under in a different color we get
X plus y is equal to 120 just multiplied
both sides by 2 you get X is equal to
120 minus y let's solve for Z in terms
of Y here multiply both sides by 2 you
get y plus Z is equal to 160 Z is equal
to 160 minus y so what's Z minus X so Z
is 160 minus y 160 minus y minus X 120
minus y 120 minus y so that is equal to
Z 160 minus y minus 120
Plus why and it's good that the Y's are
cancelling out whenever they give you
something like this you can almost let's
it's it's usually a safe guess that if
you just go forth with the algebra that
nice things will happen like this
so these Y's cancel out and we're left
with 160 minus 120 which is 40 and that
is choice B problem 183 183 if one half
of the air and a tank is removed with
each stroke of a vacuum pump so we have
one half tank per stroke I'm guessing
this is going to be a rate of change
what fraction of the original amount of
air has been removed after four strokes
oh no this is interesting okay
so after one stroke so what fraction of
the original amount of air has been
removed so let's just figure out how
much has been left right so left we
could do both actually left and then
removed so after one stroke one half of
the air in the tank is removed with each
stroke right so after one stroke you
have one half left and you had one half
removed right then after two strokes it
takes out half of the air right so it
takes out a half of this half so it
takes it so if you take out a half of
this half you have 1/4 left over and
you've also removed another fourth right
because though these add up to what was
left before after three strokes you take
out half of this so you have 1/8 left
over and you took out another eighth and
then after four strokes you have 1/16 of
the air left over and actually don't
even have to do this column after four
strokes you have 1/16 of the original
air right but they they want to know
what fraction of the original amount of
air has been removed so this is what you
have left so what's been removed is one
minus this a one- 1/16
well that's 16 over 16 minus 1 over 16
just equal to 15 over 16 choice a i
didn't have to do worry about that
column
problem
184 if the two-digit integers m and n if
the two-digit integers m and n are
positive and have the same digits but in
reverse order which of the following
cannot be the sum of m and n are the
same digits reverse order so M could be
a B and n could be B a and so which
cannot be the sum so let's just I'm just
experimenting let's see what if you add
a B and B a a B and B a so if B plus
let's see if B plus a I guess there's
two assumptions if B plus a is less than
10 let's let's do this one B plus a is
less than 10 then you would have this
digit would be B plus a and then this
digit over here would also be B plus a
right so definitely choices D and E work
so we're left with choices a B and C
because none of these fit this paradigm
right where we have the same digit twice
so all of those assume that the the that
B plus a is greater than 10 so if if B
plus a is greater than 10 then what
happens
a plus B B plus a so essentially let's
think about it a little bit if B plus a
you'll have the you'll have the ones
digit ones digit from from B plus a and
then you'll have a one up here and you'd
add one plus a plus B so you'd have B
plus a plus one right and so this will
be a two digit number and if you think
about it it's the so if we if you do the
three digits of the number right if we
do the three digits of the number this
is going to be the ones digit from B
plus a right this is going to be the
ones digit from B
plus a plus one so this number is going
to be one more than this number that's
an interesting problem this one has to
be one more than that one and so both B
and C satisfy that right one sixty five
six is one more than five and it should
work out you can we should we should be
able to figure out a B and an A that
satisfy that and then C also satisfies
that one twenty-one two is one more than
one and I wanted to make sure you
understand because it's actually pretty
interesting you know but deductive
reasoning a is the answer but if you
think about it
B we're assuming B plus a is greater
than zero so here you'd have the ones
digit of B plus a and you would carry a
one now when you add a plus B and that
one the ones digit is going to be one
greater this is going to be the ones
digit of B plus a plus one and that's
why I'm saying that the tens digit has
to be one greater than the ones that was
an interesting problem anyway see you in
the next video